hello everyone and welcome to an
extremely wild game that was played in
2016 european individual championship
between daniel dubois and croatian grand
master ante berkich
and a lot of you have reque have been
requesting to me to show more dubose
games and uh well
i i can imagine why as we've seen in the
uh previous air things masters
uh good things are happening in chess
right now
so uh i dug up this one uh i wasn't easy
i'm just kidding it was the first one
that i chose but uh you know
i'm not complaining and this is the one
i'm going to show you so without further
ado
let's check it out it features a very
nice pause the video moment
so let's see what what's happening here
with the white pieces
opens with d4 uh we have knight f6 c4
we have e6 knight f3 and the d5 so just
a normal queen's gambit declined
is on the board and bishop to g5
uh so just pinning that knight and here
bishop to b4 the vienna variation
comes with check uh dooble blocks check
and now
h6 challenging white's uh dark square
bishop so bishop goes back and now
even g5 bishop back to g3 and now
knight to e4 and now the bishop on g3 is
being pressured
and also there's a double attack on the
knight and c3 so dubo needs to defend
that knight so queen to c2
and now even h5 preparing to trap the
bishop with h4
so h3 uh but now by playing h3 you've
somewhat weakened the g3 square
and of course now black can just capture
and will force white to mess up his pawn
structure so this is exactly what uh
berkich uh did
uh now there is also a known game uh
actually from defeated candidates
tournament 2018 between uh grishok and
mamadyarov that ended in a draw knight
the c6 was played here but here
uh we have bishop captures on c3 and it
is as of move 9 that we have a
completely new game or as this is a game
from 2016 this position has never been
reached again
with b captures and now uh berkich
captures on g3 so knight captures on g3
f captures and now knight to c6 uh
continuing development
and dubo now finally strikes in the
center with e4
so dub uh kingside and queenside are
somewhat shattered
uh but it's nothing uh nothing too big
to worry about he can play king f2
bishop d3 bring the rook into the game
and if he wants he can even castle
artificially so
d captures an e4 queen captures and now
queen to d6
and here uh of course uh going after
that g3 pawn
defends it but he wanted to play king to
f2 anyway so
uh you know all works out uh bishop to
d7
black is preparing to castle queen side
and now even c5
asking black do you want to trade queens
maybe with queen to d5 or do you want to
go back
which means your queen will be somewhat
less active so queen back to e7
was played and now rook the b1 uh asking
are you castling queenside or not or are
you gonna
try and defend this some other way uh
and here berkich said
uh all right we're gonna we're gonna
castle queenside here maybe
a safer approach would be just to
continue playing f5 attack the white
queen
and only then castle uh but okay who who
can know such things we have castle's
queen side
and now there's a bit of a problem here
with the queen on
e4 maybe that's why f maybe f5 first
kick away the queen and then castle
queenside
uh with castle and queen side right away
we can see that the queen and rook are
putting a lot of pressure on this uh
pawn on b7 here and the dubois next move
is
very very obvious uh it's uh knight to
e5
so the knight of course cannot be
captured because it's checkmate queen
captures on b7 will be checkmate
so black needs to decide how to how to
deal with this black plays
f5 now but now it's a bit different
because the knight vacated the f3 square
for the white queen so queen back to f3
and now comes g4 and uh okay now it
makes sense you want to
push back the white queen capture the
knight on e5 and then black will have an
excellent position black will play
bishop to c6 and his position will be
impenetrable
even but there's a problem here because
black's position is completely lost now
we've reached the position from the
thumbnail so feel free to pause the
video
and win this game for duba while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations you must really
really enjoy the opera
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's a bishop to a6
this is what the do both played and now
there is nothing left for black to do
here
uh even if you don't capture the queen
there actually isn't a move that you can
play here
uh because uh nothing works
what will you play here you cannot move
the knight like something like knight a5
maybe to guard the b7 because there's a
triple attack on b7 now you're you're
still losing this captures
and after the king moves there's a
bishop a6 check and now the king has
nowhere to go it's
check from the rook you'd have to block
that and then it's just
checkmate so not capturing the queen is
out of the option
uh but capturing the queen also doesn't
really work but you have to play
something where you have to resign
that's how chess works
so berkich captured the queen and now
comes a lot of windmill action
so bishop captures on b7 with check king
to b8 and now you can choose uh wherever
you wherever you place the bishop it's
going to be checked to the black king
from the rook
so double starts by picking up the
knight bishop captures and c6 would
check uh only move king to c8 as uh its
check and the king has nowhere to go so
king c8 and now again bishop to b7 check
double now wants to get rid of the f3
pawn but also with checks so
uh he doesn't waste time king b8 bishop
captures an f3 again
with check from the king to c8 and
now again bishop to b7 with check king
to b8 and now
bishop to c6 with check king to c8 and
now dubo finishes the game in great
style here dubo played rook to b2
uh and he was in this position that ante
berkich resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
you could
capture the bishop of course but if you
capture the bishop white doesn't even
recapture y just goes rook
h to b1 and there is no defense against
rook to b8 checkmate
the knight covers the the d7 square and
there's nothing you can do you can't uh
make any breeding room for the king uh
you cannot move the king even moving the
rook is just made in one so
that doesn't work uh there's nothing
to be done here uh uh uh you don't have
to capture the bishop okay you could
play something else maybe you could play
rook d
fate making room for the king now if for
example rook to b1 the king can start
running away and then you have the c8
square free for your bishop so you can
do that
but here white just plays bishop
captures on d7 with check
and now again if you go here it's
checkmate so you have to uh
capture this with the queen but it
doesn't help just
rook h to b1 again threatening checkmate
and even if you play king d8 you're
gonna get rook to b8 with
check king is seven and now even the
rook captures an f8
completely winning uh if king captures
of course you pick up the queen with
check and interestingly if the rook
captures you don't even have to capture
the queen you can play knight g6 check
attack the king and the rook uh and uh
that's
uh sorry not the knight g6 check um
uh knight g6 check in this position
uh sorry uh this is what i uh this is
what i wanted to do a rook captures on a
f8 and now
uh there's nothing you there's nothing
for you to do because the queen is
hanging and now you have to move the
queen otherwise if you if you capture
this then
white can obviously just capture the
queen so
black would have to move the queen and
now comes uh
knight to g6 with check as it also
attacks the black rook checks the king
and defends the white rook and now
finally after king to d7
you can capture the rook but you don't
have to you can just play rook to f7
check king to c6 and now even this
knight checks
uh picks up the queen so there's nothing
nothing for you to do
here or or you could go up the board but
if you go up the board it's nothing
better if you go here
it's still a nice fork so again you're
gonna lose the queen
and of course if you go here then it's
mating one again rook to b8 will be
checkmate
so sorry i messed up the variation a
little bit there but uh you you uh
you got what i was talking about uh so
after rook to b2 none of this
actually happened over the board on rook
to b2 and move 26 burkitt resigned the
game
and an excellent victory for daniel
dubov in the european individual
championship 2016. i think he won eight
or nine place uh
uh if you guys are interested i can even
check
let me just check that for a second
there we go
uh
oh no 10th place he won 10 plays uh with
seven and a half points and
first place was won by ernesto inner
kiev with nine out of eleven
uh so yeah uh there you have it if you
if you'd like uh some more uh dub of
games uh
feel free to comment uh in the you know
comment section i'm gonna check them out
and of course if you have any other
suggestions you shou
use hashtag suggestion and i'm gonna
check out that game as well
uh so yeah once again i hope you guys
enjoyed it uh really wonderful stuff
truly a night at the opera that bishop
to a6 was really
really brilliant i really enjoyed that
uh but yeah
that's it uh i would like to thank david
kimura
santosh kulkarni branislav georgiovic
and mark mark davison for a contribution
to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here
thank all for watching and i will see
you soon uh continuing the coverage of
the morphe saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever
whatever else happens in the chess world
the tata still chess tournament starts
on the 15th uh thank you i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day